when I'm watching the House Democrats or
certain 20/20 candidates or their media
chums
I feel like I'm watching characters in a
cartoon series instead of
representatives of the people months
after month they're goofy they just
boldly predict president Trump's
political demise they give Americans the
impression that they have him trapped
that he's headed off the edge of the
cliff well tonight we focus on five ways
that Trump is outsmarted them all first
the relentless trashing of his economic
record if we're going to have a
recession it's going to be a smorgasbord
recession two years of a global
recession that's right
the r-word it's not in panic but it's
near panic territory it could be seeking
reelection during a recession the market
has nowhere to go but down recession is
written all over the forehead of this
economy now of course that was all bunk
the r-word that the democrats are now
most worried about that they have to
confront is record as in record breaking
stock market again today and of course
incredibly low unemployment also record
numbers there in fact economists in
Bloomberg columnist Michael strain
writes today this year the rate of
employment for people between the ages
of 25 and 54 has finally recovered from
the Great Recession and here's yet
another reason to be grateful this
Thanksgiving the economy of 2020 it's
set to have a better year what happened
to recession how do I need these people
still have jobs second there reports
that Trump's GOP wall of support was
somehow cracking sure to be his undoing
if the president United States asks or
presses the leader of a foreign country
to carry out an investigation of a
political nature that's troubling and
and I feel that there's got to be
somebody in the Republican Party who
will stand up and say that we believe in
the rule of law once that happens then
the floodgates could open there's a
chance that there will be 20 Republicans
I'm not predicting it I wouldn't bet on
it but I think there's a chance there's
a chance that you're wrong again today
Trump enjoys nine
the percent approval among Republicans
by the way has anyone checked on bill
weld lately
third Democrats in the media also warned
that Trump's tariffs against China would
prove disastrous his his trade war with
China tanking the US economy this trade
war that is tanking the economy with the
escalating trade war tank the US economy
if the trade wall were to get worse than
it could tank the whole global economy
if they get up in the morning and just
pick a few keywords that they're gonna
share all day long
of course it's another swing in a mess
our economy is booming while China's GDP
is growing at its slowest pace since the
1990s and by the way it's expected to
contract further next year fourth
Democrats believe Trump's summertime war
of words with AOC +3 would yield
political pain for both him and his
party I am NOT surprised when the
president says that for sitting members
of Congress should quote go back to
their own country he would love nothing
more than to divide our country this is
simply disruption of this administration
this sort of rhetoric has a consequence
for him this could really hurt him in
2020 now I'm not sure who that is but
the reality Trump's decision to take on
the hit girls might have made them
momentary victims but it also meant
Nancy Pelosi had to come to their
defense we just had a meeting to clear
the air and a family you have your
differences but you're still family now
this only gave them more prominence and
with the help of the faux whistleblower
were brought to number five the squad's
impeachment fantasy became a daily
reality
this was another bombshell today just
like there was a bombshell on Wednesday
the devastating testimony from
evidence of bribery the president
appeased power and violated his own now
one of the hearings ended up swinging
public opinion against Democrats
impeachment fantasy the left move on to
moved on to their next illusion a
federal judge nominated by Obama is
forcing Trump's former White House
Counsel to turn against the President to
go testify now the media was breathless
with excitement
a federal judge just ruling that former
White House Counsel Don McGann must
cooperate with the impeachment
investigation now this is a huge win for
Democrats this is really significant
this changes the dynamics of impeachment
never mind the fact that even if
compelled to show up McGann could waive
off every question is privileged so once
again Democrats thought they had Trump's
number but in fact he really had theirs
if the speaker doesn't watch out her new
nickname will be wily Pelosi
[Music]
did I say pillow safe well I'm Wiley
Pelosi I'm on with the magnets perfect
now no matter what the democrats throw
at Trump they just can't take them down
it's driving them crazy their
predictions about the president staying
power have been spectacular flops but
here are a few predictions from yours
truly
the president will get nominated with
overwhelming support from his party and
independence while Democrats nominate
someone with almost zero ability to
connect with Americans outside of major
cities and despite their series of
political debacles they will learn very
little and just end up blaming the
voters once again and that's the angle